but he has switched and he has switched
successfully to this move one d4 queen's
pawn opening what will we see magnus do
here
uh will we see him go for the queen's
gun but declined where prague has had a
lot of games
most likely we are heading in that
direction
black can bring his dark square bishop
out with a check magnus has played that
was well this tournament but no it is
the queen's gun be declined and one of
the main lines so far i'm kind of hoping
for a slav
just just to kind of test
the statistics but uh no instead the
bishop has come out this is actually
quite uh it's a solid but dynamic
opening it's called the rogozin defense
yeah magnus has barely played the slav
actually since 2016 his world
championship match against karakin and
the kind of ensuing months meanwhile
yeah very topical position and prague's
teammate in the olympiad in chennai uh
gukesh of course on board one had a lot
of success against the regozin
he got some fantastic positions with
white
against this traditionally quite solid
opening white's queen stepping back now
this is one of the main moves
and question for black how does black
challenge in the center white is
slightly behind in peace development
white has wasted actually a move with
his queen he came forward with the check
he dropped the queen back later on
uh so she's on a good square now but she
has spent a few moves getting there
and uh here black i mean there's several
moves you can move the black rook next
to the black king you can trade off a
set of pawns you can retreat black
starts going bishop
a variety of moves for magnuson i think
prague just wants to get out of this
opening he wants to
maybe ask magnus a few questions along
the way yeah starting here yeah he
chooses a
safe and solid
and reliable variation actually with the
white pieces i mean because there was
the possibility early on to kind of
really liven up the game but here i
think this is just a sensible chess
and yeah white has moved the queen a few
times but then the argument is well take
a look at the black knight that is
sitting on the left it's in front of its
pawns and this knight will have to
relocate itself at some point or other
there's a lot of venom actually there's
a lot of tricks can
kind of concealed in this opening setup
for white white is also very flexible so
one idea that guke used his indian
colleague there was to castle the white
king on the queen side on the other side
of the board
at some point if black opens the center
in the wrong way and uh yeah you could
i was going to say this is also a very
trendy move black's knight sitting on
the edge of the board now
if i'm not mistaken this was used by
ding in the candidates tournament
it was also uh featured in the olympiad
um this black knight now sitting on the
edge attacking whitespawn trying to
force prague to make a decision
and uh the key here is whether white can
step forward and gain a bit of space
with his pawn structure magnus spieling
uh sorry this was a idea by caruana
sorry against ding no you know you had
it you had it right ding against uh
caruana yeah ding again in the
candidates
and uh there you're totally right white
step forward with the pawn
one square
yeah and that game was very very
interesting
and uh if it's good enough for caruana
it's good enough for carson he follows
all the top games he follows the trends
i'm slightly surprised that prague is
thinking here for almost a minute now
because
uh in terms of kind of topicality and
how recent those kind of important games
were in the candidates tournament he was
following that tournament for sure he
would have seen this surely he has an
idea
what do you think simon uh
good idea by magnus to try and surprise
his young opponent
yeah i mean i think often whoever gets
first surprising uh gets the first
strike and and it looks like magnus has
got the first surprise in i i'm i'm i am
surprised it's the first surprise
if that makes sense because as you
mentioned it is something i i would have
thought prague would be well aware of
he's just clarifying the center now this
makes some sense but you're also losing
a lot of tension by making this exchange
this is this often
heads the position more to equality
because you you keep
you don't have that flexibility with the
pawn that you have before but he's i
think he's just going for simple
development and again you can't really
fault that maybe he'll bring his dark
square bishop out next and i'm i'm
secretly hoping or hoping that he
castles queenside i really want to see
the white king go queen side i don't
think it will now it's too risky but i i
wanted to see opposite side castling
because when that occurs you often get
some of the most interesting attacking
positions the one thing i would say
though is that black's knight magnus's
night that he's moved this is his
problem piece and this whole variation
he's moved it to force or to tempt
prague into exchanging pawns um but that
knight is now it's it's a pretty bad
square because um you know it you might
even get it trapped in some lines so
this is the one the one issue really
that magnus has in this position
yeah so at some point he might well just
kind of take a few tempe it takes a long
time but just kind of
trace its path back to maybe a more
solid square and okay he doesn't want to
take the
the slow approach here magnus carson he
goes to challenge white in the center
and immediately this feels very
ambitious
it could be very good black is a head in
development after all white's king is
still stuck in the middle of the board
why not open things up while your
opponent's king is there as a sitting
duck
i guess the most critical now would be
to capture this pawn if you leave it to
run for example if the white king
castles often it's actually quite nice
for black to gain a bit of space now the
white bishop is forced back to a more
passive square and later the black pawns
will start trying to advance on this
left side so i'm expecting prague not to
think for too long and then just capture
this pawn
i would have thought that magnus would
be very happy the way this has gone um
one of the issues with this position for
white is this dark square bishop you can
get similar similar positions in this
opening but with the dark square bishop
again you've got to look at your own
pieces which are good and bad and that
bishop is trapped it's trapped behind
white's pawns they're blocking it in
meaning it's a bit useless often you get
the same position but with the bishop on
the other side of the pawns which should
be much more favorable because it will
it can definitely put more pressure on
black's position so
my first instinct is yeah i think magnus
has got a little surprising buddhist
night jump and i love the activity
behind his last move and i i'm thinking
he'll be very happy just indicating also
by how long prague has taken on his move
here i think magnus will be quite happy
with this this position so far yeah i
mean easy play for black at some point
he might bring his bishop out at some
point he might just kind of put his rook
on a semi-open file easy moves for black
less easy moves for white and prague
deep in thought he's still doing okay
objectively but he needs to play a bit
more actively over the next few turns
yeah i feel that this is brewing up
really nicely this position
so many possibilities and somehow both
sides have got like the
bad pieces
and uh whilst this is a critical moment
i
well we are running a quiz of the day
where we are asking our viewers to
caption this particular picture
and the best caption will win one year
subscription of chass 24 premium
membership and there we see the picture
and rahul agarwal says
when you realize your uber eats have
crossed one 1 500 bucks already
that is a oh my god moment i wonder what
hans neiman's super breeze bill is on
i'm also curious many days ago i know
and uh jens says when you spend house
preparing for playing magnus and he
opens with one a4
also it's like
yeah and pierre says
i hope no one saw that
what that kind of looks like it does
yeah
i love those so keep those captions
comment coming and remember you can
tweet them using the hashtag chess
champs and remember the best caption
wins one year chess 24 premium
membership yeah and after three minutes
prague makes his move he does make his
move it's the move we predicted here you
just didn't want to allow black to
continue advancing on that left flank he
does capture that black pawn
temporarily magnus is upon down he's
happy to just improve his worst place
piece re-centralize that knight
white sea pawn isn't running anywhere
anytime soon so he will capture it on
the next couple of moves
prague he just needs to castle i'm sorry
simon i don't think it's it's a great
castle on the left side anymore i
totally agree i mean there's too many
open lines on the left hand side so i
agree that white needs to get his king
safe i mean just stick to the basics you
don't need to do anything outrageously
uh you know crazy at this point of the
game not yet uh not yet no get castle
develop you know and then you can start
planning uh your next steps you know um
and uh he's got you know i he's he's
moving he's slowing down a bit isn't he
prague it just indicates he's not
entirely happy with this he normally
plays the opening very confidently very
quickly
um so again i think why he's opening
choice of magnus here
and with that night retreat there's
probably a big threat by magnus of
opening up the center
pushing that d-pawn forward and uh
whoa simon how did he make that move
without using his hands
he's had his arms crossed the whole time
that trick again this is the trick that
makes them so strong i don't know
telekinesis yeah that's it the jedi mind
trick
and um well with this last move now now
the black knight has has some ideas of
diving in and
you know prague a prank i wouldn't have
thought he wants to castle now because
he'll lose his very nice light square
bishop um and you don't lose that piece
so he's moving his knight and this is
quite a kind of good position
because he wants to control the square
in front of what we call the isolated
pawn black's pawn in the middle of the
board and i think it was spassky who who
actually said it's not the isolated pawn
which is the weakness it's the square in
front of it
so
i think it's this square in the middle
that prague's trying to get his knight
into but
i'd be a little bit scared because i
haven't castled yet right yeah i mean
come on you've got a castle prank maybe
the knight can jump in yeah what about
that for a moment i was thinking that
too played it and uh here he goes we see
a reaction from prague maybe we can get
him on the picture because it looks like
this wasn't possible it looks like white
is going to gobble up this black bishop
but suddenly after the knight captures
the white bishop this is a fork the king
and queen a royal fork
both attacked at the same point at the
same time really weird move now you've
retreated your knight the black knight
has jumped forward you can't take this
bishop your queen is attacked so one of
the black knight is going to take one of
the white bishops
if you capture this knight then also you
will regret leaving your king in the
center this long it's a check
you have to move the knight that just
did move you have to retreat it back to
where it came from and a block
weird weird stuff yeah i mean not
castling
you know it's a very strange very
strange you could have just done that
first and now as you mentioned he's
going to lose one of his bishops so i
don't know how bad that is but we know
that magnus is a great believer in the
bishop pair he loves having the two
bishops and long term um if especially
if he can get rid of his isolated pawn
uh that could be quite bad news for
prague in any ensuring ending um so
which bishop would you give up
i'd give up the light squared one no
questions for example just step back
with the queen uh allow a capture here
and then at least this dot square bishop
has a nice home
uh on this kind of long diagonal i might
be giving up two two bishops actually
because the knight can jump forward and
take this guy yeah take this guy and
oh he goes for my recommendation
not sure now
magnus instantly captures that bishop he
has the bishop pair we do actually we
predicted it well there guys yeah we've
predicted the continuation makes a nice
change
yeah it's about magnus having the two
bishops white only having one white's
knights are okay but uh
i mean it's still it's maybe magnus yeah
i mean it's probably still okay for
white isn't it because white does have
this lovely square we mentioned in the
middle of the board you know you can put
a piece there and it can never be
attacked by pawn this is the strength of
playing against the isolated pawn it
doesn't have any friends next to it it's
like what do we call it dilly dilly no
mates i don't know why dilly is there
even a name did i just make that did he
actually is anyone knowing
because that's not true
this is dilly no mates oh magnus heard
your excitement
the dilly dilly the d porn
i don't know a dilly i'm just billy
feels a bit silly right now
you're a silly dilly
remember it's all about the drama today
you guys yeah that's a silly delay
as well
look at the clock times dramatically
there
five minutes down on the clock he's
nervous and magnus immediately frowns
after that last move normally when
magnus rounds his opponent
has slipped up
but uh okay it looks sensible to me
blocking gilly in the center of the
board
tilly i mean yeah i think it's i think
that i came up with diddy i'm sure it's
a dog's name that's more of a dog's name
than human name sorry if there's loads
of dilly's out there i apologize to all
dillies but i i'm pretty sure that's the
dog's name it's like you know like shep
billy i've heard tilly as the name tilly
tilly billy of course billy billy is
normal and from now on whenever we have
a bad d pawn it's going to be a dilly
dilly night it's a good deep then it's
david if it's a bad one
i like that
silly
dilly well we've really gone off a
little bit on tangent here
per usual and
enjoying it
i don't think magnus should be listening
to our commentary i don't think it would
help his chest much either to
there is the question here maybe black
can throw the queen
all the way into the position but um i
still think it's pretty balanced here
but actually
uh look at the bar
gotta get it in
i just realized it actually has gone
somewhat it is israel is there a really
strong idea here then somewhere i'm
trying to search i don't see it to be
honest maybe this is the start of
magnus's idea so magnus loves pushing
his uh rook sports especially on the
queen side uh it's a noticeable kind of
habit of his but he kind of has enacted
a two-three move plan with this last
pawn push he wants to activate black's
light squad bishop which is still
sitting at home still uh kind of asleep
he wants to activate it and start
attacking the white queen so um
he's still laughing there magnus um just
to show the top players in the world
they always have two to three move plans
at a time he's pushed his pawn forward
first of all just opening up his rook
maybe his rook wants to kind of swing
across and start attacking especially if
white's king sits on the side of the
board but more importantly i think his
idea is to actually push his pawn and
activate his bishop on this diagonal
where it actually has some big targets
if the bishop lands there
maybe trouble for white you've got to be
really careful where you put your pieces
now
so uh yeah interesting multi-purpose
kind of flexible i love that move yeah
we often see that moving in opening
called the budapest where
if white castles that rook um can swing
all the way over and proud has he
forgotten how to castle in this game
because you know it is important to
castle now your idea of bringing the
bishop out springs to mind isn't it
but both ideas are very tempting here
and magnus looks really confused he was
frowning there i mean you can defend
this bishop this kind of semi-attacked
by white's rook and now the bishop
coming out it's it's a killer
i mean why are you not castling prague i
mean you got a castle just stick to the
basics i mean whether it's good or bad
you can't leave your king in the middle
in a position like this it's not gonna
last so i i i really like this move that
magnus played and he has just gone for
the light square bishop coming out
attacking the queen gaining another
tempo and um yeah
how on earth is pregnant going to
unravel can we can we try and do some
repair work for white here
maybe he also has to push his a pawn
up the board and at least here he could
block with his knight but already prague
is on the defense and
magnus looks in charge i mean already
the queen is coming out potentially
threatening not some nasty checkmating
ideas threatening this pawn
it's hanging by a thread now for prague
computer really doesn't like his
position clock is against him
and maybe it's just that inexperience
compared to magnus in these must win
situations just play your normal game it
feels like prague is trying to be a bit
too flashy uh just by keeping his king
in the center he's trying to be creative
trying to prioritize other things but
the position will become open at some
point black's pieces are going to
improve and okay he solidifies the
center
and i guess he plans to meet this bishop
move
ugh
i was going to say with a queen retreat
it just looks odd though the queen going
back where she came from this is going
to be
one two three four the fourth time this
queen has moved no fifth time this queen
has moved sorry and it will only be move
18. wow
yeah it feels wrong it just feels wrong
look at the power of this bishop
especially
cutting down on this diagonal
trouble for prague in this game too and
remember a lot is at stake the winner in
the ftx crypto cup uh gets a big portion
of the hundred thousand dollars worth of
bitcoins and there's also that very cool
nft trophy up for grabs with the pitcher
of that player who wins the tournament
and an exclusive fan edition of that nft
trophy will be up for auction for 72
hours after
this round
of matches finishes so when we have
decided a winner for 72 hours you can
bid on an exclusive version of that nft
trophy on
chesschamps.io so be ready for that two
moves on the board is it looking any
better for prague
unfortunately not it's the two moves we
predicted black's bishop lining up on
this fantastic diagonal it did hit the
white queen which retreated back to her
starting square five moves now by that
white queen and she's back home so yeah
don't try this
kids yeah don't bring your queen out to
early she might get kicked around
all right magnus he is still with a lot
of time on the clock more than 10
minutes with a big smile on his face
constantly laughing he must be enjoying
this position with the black pieces it's
looking good do you think he will win
this game
i think he's the favorite still a long
way to go you have great pieces as black
but
the next step to kind of turn that into
something more tangible into a material
advantage or into a bigger attack still
takes work what do you guys think
yeah
prague's ready to castle right i mean
finally and yeah if prague can get
castle then that does take a lot of
danger out of positions so is there any
way this this is why magnus is slowed
down now i mean just like in a game of
chess you can play a lot of moves very
quickly and you should play a lot of
moves quite quickly especially in this
time control and their natural moves but
you only get like three critical moments
um and this is certainly a critical
moment because you could let the
advantage go away and i think it is an
advantage at the moment if you let white
gets what he wants so i think he's gotta
come up with some disruptive moves now
you know the first four try to see if
you can bring the queen in but maybe
that doesn't achieve anything then you
look at other areas is there any any
kind of threats that magnus can create
to try and put white off castling maybe
pushing some pawns uh this seems quite
logical but
does it
now prague come on just castle you've
got a castle at some point nothing else
you can do basically you've got a castle
here you can't leave your king there any
longer you know yeah no he certainly
can't
but can he castle i mean are there going
to be some traits
because there's a lot of unpleasant
pressure along the
light squares
yeah that's true let's investigate this
ivanka um so the big question after
black has brought his rook
to a more central square is can white
castle and you're talking about trade so
first i guess you could capture the
bishop
and uh here white knight is actually
pinned along this diagonal so the white
knight cannot recapture
uh if you take back with the pawn i
think you
might be in big trouble after a bishop
capture here again you've got to be
careful of this pin so you have to take
back the central pawn
oh i say big trouble maybe white's just
about surviving he does indeed castle
here um for example an attack against
the white knight could just be defended
against
it's hanging by a thread for white but
maybe it is hanging together that's the
key he had to castle though i mean for
better or worse his king is safe at
least sometimes you just got to go for
it even if you're not that comfortable
um
but yeah i mean those exchanges are are
very close to being extremely strong for
black but if he doesn't you know if he
doesn't
find something soon i think white should
be okay here
like for instance now i mean this but
there's so many captures on the board
for instance you can actually go bishop
takes knight
and then the whole idea is that you know
if you go bishop takes bishop rook takes
rook
that's my idea nice sopranos
[Laughter]
a bit of uh scarface in miami you know i
don't know where that came from simon
nice i like it um i hear black woodwind
material either the knight or bishop
knight or rook sorry on this diagonal um
he has gone for your move for banker
bishop takes bishop and that forces a
recapture with a pawn so bad bishop now
for white
yeah that that's that's a horrible move
to have to play right to take with the
pawn there because you've just killed
your own bishop look at white's only
bishop it's just pointing at a brick
wall now and for the rest of the game
that bishop is going to be a bad piece
so this is just the kind of position i
think magnus would enjoy i missed this
capture nicely pointed out there ivanka
and
i think
you know black black has just a nice
edge now with the better pieces as
simple as that yeah
oh
what will happen for prague we're going
to take a trip
to miami where uh tanya is following all
the action do you guys tonya think that
prague is in big trouble in this game
kaya well the first game might come to
haunt prague that was his big moment his
big chance and we know that against the
world champ when you get these
opportunities you really have to make
the most of it but the thing is it's
just so hard to be madness regardless of
the position there is you have to win a
winning position as well against him he
does everything to make it hard and the
kind of opening he's played it's been a
dream start for him we've got grand
master alejandro ramirez joining us to
break down this position for us ali this
looks like trouble for prague oh it's
absolutely trouble and you can tell that
he spent some time white black did
capturing this bishop on d3 and you can
see this beautiful dark square bishop
that's why it's a different color than
the rest of the pieces because i just
want to highlight how beautiful it is it
controls this diagonal it means that
this knight is going to be awkward for a
while the moment that you castle this
rook is going to land directly on the
line of fire and that means that there's
going to be a lot of pressure in the
center
thought that he was out maneuvering
carlson in a strategical battle but he
must have completely missed this
beautiful a5 b6 bishop a6 slow but very
powerful this one has been flawless
played by magnus in the opening but game
one that was a big opportunity there
magnus has been very shaky in the first
rounds of this tournament and prague had
to pounce on his opportunity the more
the magnus plays the better he gets and
i think he's now fired up and you can
see that's trouble for pragananda
there we have it gaia trouble for prague
and the thing is that when magnus gets
his opportunities he doesn't let them
slip
yeah that's true we rarely see magnus
carlsen slip up prague in trouble it's
all about then that beautiful black
bishop yeah that beautiful black bishop
now the beautiful black knight in the
middle of the board as well
it's if you compare and contrast the two
bishops i mean simon said white's bishop
is terrible but it only looks terrible
because uh it has this fantastic uh
rival
the black light square bishop
opposite-colored bishops tends to mean
drawish tendencies uh drawing qualities
of the position but not here this is
just
um
it's just so beautiful it's just about
again can magnus turn that into winning
a pawn can he turn it into maybe
long-term good night versus bad bishop
scenario he needs to turn it into
something magnus because it isn't the
type of advantage that will last
forever and okay first of all he
activates his queen
nice and logical
prague needs to survive he needs to
break out
does he try and kick away this black
knight from the center of the board he's
just kind of tangled in knots tangled in
webs and he does try to kick the knight
back
i have to say magnus as accurate as ever
i just love that queen move i mean it
just completely ties down
the white rooks
and uh big question now what do you do
with the night i guess you have to
go back
because uh and i would probably go back
to
nope okay commentators curse as always
so
i mean this this kind of move reminds me
of something bobby fisher was quite
famous for right giving up a beautiful
piece for a bad piece but as david was
maybe pointing out trying to get
something very tangible so black needs
to transfer his positional advantage
into a material advantage or something
direct so surely he's got an idea here
um
i'm just trying to find out what the
idea is but uh there's obviously
pressure against the sea pawn
is just gonna apply more pressure and
maybe the queen can come over to the
queen side yeah i can't maybe can even
dive in all the way to the e3 square
that looks good doesn't it yeah yeah
let's show this on the board because
prague is coming under some concrete
threats now first threat to his knight
it's attacked from the bishop the knight
cannot move the bishop is pinning it to
the rook behind and of course the black
queen teaming up against the peace as
well so you have to defend it if you
defend it like this as you guys
mentioned this looks like a very scary
check hitting the king the king has to
run away to the corner
something feels like it's going to drop
now at the very least i guess you can
just kind of move your rook across
and
i mean maybe white can survive but it's
not pretty
another idea is you also mentioned the
assignment would be to swing the queen
this way at some point for example if
the white rook defends its knight can
you jump to this side of the wood go
after this one
i don't know it still feels like it
should be uh should be holding together
for white if he defends correctly but
the question big question now is um this
knight which is attacked you defend it
with this rook by stepping up blocking
any checks do you defend it by stepping
across
and uh prague with
around five minutes now he needs to
defend these
threats and he also needs to cross his
fingers and hope that no pawns are
dropping off this is the big weakness
the backward sea pawn
we call it backward because it can never
ever step forward without being captured
and
it feels like somehow magnus wants to
win this guy
it's just how is he going to do so
i don't see a breakthrough to be honest
if white just defends his knight
i do like your idea of jumping into the
queen and just moving the rook across i
mean this this looks very natural
because black's improved every single
one of his pieces if you look at a black
piece they're all applying pressure to
something so this would be there you
know okay not sure what to do just going
to put my piece in and here
white has to move the knight so this
would be very forcing and this would be
a key position if uh
but you can't actually win a pawn here
i've just realized because of the back
back
back uh back rank right yeah not quite
if for example you trade off everything
it looks like you can finally pick off
this backward pawn but if you do capture
of course
you get checkmated on the back rank uh
so we are actually heading in this
direction we will
see the white king park itself in the
corner there was no way you could have a
step across and kind of walk into this
eternal pin you had to hide out in the
corner of the ward the white king also
vulnerable on the back rank and here
magnus can he do something else i have a
feeling just knowing magnus he wants to
kind of play a tricky move like
inserting his queen as far into his
opponent's camp as possible
so now
once the white knight moves at least he
can think about taking this pawn this
loose pawn on a2 he wants to win
something magnus
that looks good i mean it looks
horrendous for white to be honest i
think i mean white's totally tied down
and
he did i mean maybe he's going to put
the queen in there after the night jump
it's sort of a similar idea and
white's pieces are really just
suffocating a bit here and black's piece
is still ready to jump in i mean your
queen move might even be more accurate
right and we're going to get this
variation now
and uh he's gone
for the end game careful of the back
spanker he does love his end game
is not going to walk into it he's not
going to surely get checkmated on his
back rank
no he he sees that and uh pushes forward
with his g pawn and uh look how that
pawn kind of controls the night circuits
as well
white's knight can never jump forward
anymore the white knight in order to get
back in the game will have to retreat at
some point but it has no safe squares
and big threat to winner pawn
magnus is going to up the pressure this
is one weakness the isolated pawn on the
a2 square also a weakness
do you think magnus is also perhaps
going to push the a pawn as well as far
as up
up it can go and then just move the
bishop to if you can i'm not sure i
would want to fix my pawn on a light
square to be honest but um i mean if you
could
fix this pawn here then easy target and
black will win the game
yeah prague still a lot of defense to be
done he might have survived the worst
but uh yeah it's an uphill struggle he
defends the pawn with this rook but the
white rook is now passive
yeah
yeah i think that's the only move
actually with the brook i mean you have
to kind of grit your teeth and play ugly
chests
hold on hold that door
i mean you could try pushing the pawn
forwards now i mean but you might only
do that if it's very forcing i mean i
want to try to still win a pawn somehow
so i could do that but uh the white
knight also has no squares it can move
to because if it does then you're going
to lose a pawn so there's many sort of
different ways you can try to do this i
mean would this pawn push allow the
white knight to retreat though you can
push it one square forward well that's
what i want to do yeah again but then
you take the time i just take the point
yeah yeah and uh because of the tension
between these rooks maybe white survives
yeah the white knight is defending its
rook down here so
yeah right now it's just about how
magnus can increase the advantage if it
were me i would be wanting to kind of
bring the rook in and go for a second
weakness maybe magnus knowing him he
will preface this by
improving the black king
bunch of choice for the world champion
and okay clock time's now around level
so prague still has chances to save this
game white needs to improve his king in
the meantime
yep
he's on the back foot though i mean this
would be a great save if prank can now
save this position um
it's you know it'd be a great great
result for him because let's just you
know the tournament standings if prague
loses this game the only way you can win
the whole competition is by winning the
next two games
and that is going to be a really hard
thing to achieve so
key game so far here a draw would be a
fantastic result for him
yeah and is it that time of day ivanka
predictions
is black going to win this game oh yeah
percentages percentages
uh stats
stats
i'll be very interested here what stats
you've got lined up here ivanka so um
yeah what date for uh the magnus to win
what percentage
it guys
no pressure you've been 100 correct so
far
100 percent correct
the biggest day of pregnancy
so magnus to win come on
this position it looks so good um
okay
i'm going to go
55
55.
what's wrong with you normally you're
normally a 90 percenter
did you expect that dave i didn't expect
to be so low yeah i thought it'd be up
there in the 80s or something at least
at least yeah
wow okay 55. it's just i've been so
confident with my other predictions and
then you know things have turned around
and i've had to kind of just start
doubting yourself
don't doubt yourself go for it
but do you just have faith in practice
defensive skills maybe that's the reason
well no i would just base it on the fact
that
i do no i think this position is
terrible i mean
uh i think that there will be at least
56.
push it up a percentage okay yeah okay
i'll round up to 60. okay i'll go up 10
65 there you go so do you think prague
has what uh 30 drawing 35 drawing yeah
and five percent winning chance
yeah i i think he's got
right zero percent okay
there you go
well there's always there's always that
i know there's always like a mouse slip
there's always something going to go
wrong but i like to live life on the
edge you know i'm going to go for it so
you're getting six certainty confidence
is key i i mean i think magnus is big
favorite to to win this one i mean okay
now white's going for a little counter
attack i mean if you can get that knight
in the game
and that knight is trying to target one
of black's pawns right we're gonna get
in the game because uh after this rook
steps forward the black record is also
gonna step forward as well and just keep
its eye on or hang on maybe the bishop
can come down and attack oh so many
possibilities i think prague just wants
to curl up into a ball and defend
everything he wants to put his knight on
a passive square he wants to hope that
there's no way through for black
but uh yeah interesting standoff white's
gonna have two passive pieces black is
gonna have two active pieces but
i don't see an immediate breakthrough i
don't think exchanging off black's
bishop for the white knight is going to
win the game
uh black's bishop is just too good
so what next prague looks a bit more
confident now than he did as well
magnus is burning a lot of time trying
to find this kind of next step forward
white's knight is just going to park
itself behind the white rook and what do
you do next
as as carlson okay here we go
the black rook i hang up two different
pawns ivanka's idea now of the black
bishop coming in it's a threat there we
go the white knight
poor poor piece but nice stable it was
necessary yeah maybe get the knight
stable then but then you've got to win
that right so uh oh he's getting all
crafty yeah black's bishop wants to come
and attack this white rook kick it off a
light square a little regular
and um that's that's a nice idea
actually i didn't didn't see that one
keeping the frets alive very clever yeah
and uh we can point out the threat now
magnus uh utilizing his bishop on this
square here he's just going to do a
zigzag as simon mentioned this is maybe
the most natural move the bishop kind of
with its kind of gaze on these diagonals
traps the white knight but instead he
found a more direct route he's going to
zigzag
forward to attack this rook and how do
you save the pawn white's rook is stuck
defending the pawn in front of it
how do you save it i don't see it king
is just so bad it's gone up to 61 that's
for sure no doubt about it here i mean
uh well you're going to lose a pawn i
mean you're a pawn down but also
the bishop is is really so much better
than knight in nearly every position um
and that that's a long term issue as
well as being a pawn down doesn't it i
mean
i i
maybe how can you fight how can you even
fight here do you just bring your king
across and as soon as you get hit
maybe you could try and go active uh
black can win this born attacking the
white knight the white knight moves
promise i guess black just steps back
black just says okay if one opponent
pocketed that one i will i will just
start marching soon
he does play the king move white's king
was just terrible in the corner yeah the
problem is white can continue attacking
pawns but everything's just defended for
black
and this two versus one will eventually
most likely win the game
well he has to go for this i mean
there's just no other option
and maybe the knight can go to a
different square but no
if goes to the e2 square and i think
we're going to see the line that we have
on the analysis board yeah
at least here you've kind of uh okay
you're hitting the black rook at least
when it retreats you've rendered it
passive uh the black rook is kind of
stuck defending the pawn next to it
for a while for example if you step
forward again the black rook is forced
to kind of passively defend these two
pawns so you've activated your pieces
with white your pieces have
not been better than this for the whole
game but you are pawn down yeah yeah i
mean prank he's just trying to go for
practical chances
maybe he'll just put everything on dark
squares king on a dart's going to put
his pawn under square this pawn on dark
square and he'll say okay
at least it's going to be difficult for
black to convert
one other thing that i saw was that
maybe instead of moving the knight to
attack the pawn
maybe the king can just step
step forward with the idea oh well
magnus
magnus wow
he doesn't even go back to defend this
pawn he sets his rook back one square
and the computer that doesn't like that
magnus he's reacting what is his idea if
rook takes pawn right now
i guess it's bishop d1 is it i mean he
wants the rook and pawn ending is that
right really i mean
maybe for example if white defends maybe
this is winning for black but with rook
and games
it's always less clear right
i would rather have more pieces on the
board i agree i agree i mean this is
this seems strange to
swap the bishop for for that night
because
it did seem that knight was not a
fantastic piece i think he wants the a
pawn
i think if you go to grab that uh
yeah he's gonna put his rook down to the
second nope simon you were absolutely
right yeah he played so quickly as well
yeah i mean uh he seemed to react magnus
has he missed something have we missed
something
uh
i mean first of all what happens if you
just defend the night with your ah if
you defend it with the king i guess
there'll be a trade and maybe black
doesn't take this pawn black goes to the
second rank and too many targets here
uh still looks very tricky doesn't it
i mean it's a i mean normally magnus
decisions are
spot on when it comes to exchanges i've
noticed this that he's incredibly clever
uh i i don't know if that's the case
here or not but uh generally the the
rook and pawn ending is going to be very
hard to defend uh for prague he's got
chances of course but yeah i mean do you
even need i mean if the king goes across
you can
bring your rook in as well if you want
to if you really want to keep that
bishop but
um
still still tough for whiteness very
tough i'm surprised the evaluation bar
says it's less than one now
in black's favor because it still looks
like he'll win a porn and prague is
going to be on the defensive for the
rest of the game under one minute now
the young indian
i mean if it wasn't magnus carlsen you
would be quite confident that you kind
of improved your position with white you
have some drawing chances now but
black against the best end game player
in history
not going to be easy prague will need
all of his fighting uh his fighting
spirit here who do you think is the next
best endgame player of all time so you
you said magnus
best endgame player and who would you
who'd you put up there with magnus we
had the move that you predicted is not
nothing changed um
who have you tricky
it's a tricky question is magnus by far
the best
i wouldn't say by far but i mean in this
era where everyone is so much better at
defending than they used to be just 20
30 years ago
and he's still the dominant end game
player
i would say yes yeah i think it also was
different time then because i remember
in the old books you kind of read all
about the germans how they used to got
to set on stage and they'd be like no
let's stop the game and then they would
crack out crack open the books and bring
their friends around and everyone would
work together to find these amazing
incredible endgame resources now
you can't do that what's happening david
very strange move there i mean moving
the king away from the center i mean
that's not a blanket move is it weird
but he's allowing a check
i mean i guess he's going to go for
dilly the d pawn
silly dilly and try to try to round that
one up that's that's the idea and trying
to trying to get into a a drawn position
that prague is pretty confident because
this is one if you swap off the a pawn
and the d-pawn
then this is this is one of the first
brook ending positions you should know
but you don't have to do that yeah look
at magnus he we see his screen there he
was very happy to push his rooks pawn
forward alice the a pawn and he i mean
he'll do this in any position opening
middle game end game and now white can't
keep his a pawn alive his equivalent
prague was banking on the fact that he
could win one of black's two remaining
pawns on the left on the left half of
the board but
that left half maybe black can just sit
and
i mean there's no threat for white the
black king can start improving now
and the black pawns can move
it just feels odd to go for this
willingly when the white king was so
well placed in the center
but i mean is this one so winning you
know because after all white does have a
threat of actually sliding the rook over
one square to the left attacking the
pawn and then one pawn will drop
never said winning just uh
maybe it was easier okay and um
i mean also
black can at some point put his rook on
a square that defends both of the two
black pawns so if the black king can
centralize
it's not 100 clear
to me whether you can win one of those
two black pawns
time getting very short for both players
i mean uh worth just keeping an eye on
the clock there they're both getting
quite close to having only a minute left
and it looks like that will be the
situation so it's really going to go on
in-game instinct uh shortly and i think
prague practically you can sort of sense
him when he does this sort of bouncing
you know when he starts bouncing about
you can sense he i think he feels a bit
more confident and he gets that he uses
that innate energy doesn't he to sort of
uh transform it onto the board and
i expect a lot of these technical
positions what i mean technical
positions
if another pair of pawns get exchanged
off that prague will have drilled
so often with his coach ramesh i mean
it's the first kind of endings you
really train so
he's he's
probably still
holding
with about
45 percent
i reckon
so your prediction was spot on javanco
as always
he steps back with the rook and the
whole idea is simply to force the rook
to capture the pawn and then he will
slide to the middle of the board and
attack the pawn so the d pawn will fall
off
poor dilly poor dilly he's always a good
she probably she was always a goner she
was she yeah she was good she didn't she
had a decent time did actually
44 moves she got a lot of attention she
did yeah there's like i just kind of
want to get back to the board because
i'm super excited about one moment like
here the black rook can actually slide
away from being in front of its own pawn
and
how is this positioned because to me
it's super unclear
yeah i mean when this is like a very
standard rook ending um you get this
often where you have an extra pass pawn
and the the basic rule when you've got
the extra pass pawn is ideal square for
your rook behind the passport second
best square for the rook next to the
past pawn worst square for your rook in
front of the pass pawn and here you've
got the second best situation as you
pointed out you've anchor it's not the
best but it's it's pretty good having it
next to the pawn and the winning
technique is to try and bring the king
over right you try to zoom the black
king over to help uh the a pawn and push
it down the board and i would not be
happy defending this position at all let
alone against the best end game player
of all time and i mean david do you
think this is a technical draw or how
would you go about do you have to create
counter play on the king side maybe for
white i mean yeah it's
it's really hard to
to know what their actual
if this is a draw or not well i mean i
mean david you know better than me i
would before so i mean but you're right
simon i mean i've spent dozens of hours
maybe more just studying these end games
where black has or one side has this
extra a porn and even after all that i
still don't know uh exactly we're still
not 100 sure on exactly what is winning
as you guys said if you have to look to
the side of the pawn
usually you have fantastic chances i
like what magnus has done by the way um
just this white king maybe was heading
towards pawns on this side to create
some distraction counter play and he's
just said no i'm going to
kind of force i'm going to create this
kind of force field this barrier
for the white king that it can't break
through and now black is pretty much
ready to start going across you kick the
rook away and when the rook has finally
moved then the black king will start uh
heading towards this pawn to help so
okay prague meanwhile defending well as
uh equally well he's just trying to
create this opposition to block off
black's king
from advancing
and i mean normally when you're
defending these positions as far as i'm
aware you should be trying to push your
king-side pawns in anticipation for
black's king coming to the other side of
the board and then you normally
counter-attack black's pawns on that
area of the ball which is highlighted
that's the traditional way of trying to
trying to defend this because you can't
keep the black king from advancing
forever it will come in so you need to
get that counter play and it's often
just a race situation i mean i think
it's clear this game is kind of critical
look at magnus uh let's go back to the
players because he just reacted there he
frowned he went back he's at 20 seconds
and uh he's not happy
uh at all with what's happened he knows
he had a big advantage but it could have
been bigger than this
ah and yeah i think with best play maybe
it is a draw just because white's king
is so active and he made that with 11
seconds left on the board yeah he blocks
up that right side of the board but
white can open it up later why i can
also give a check kicking the black king
back to a worse square
i mean what a save this will be i mean
if prague saves this it'll be tremendous
i mean like he's you know the young kid
is showing great in-game skills and it
keeps him in the match you know he's got
white in the next game he wins that you
can still win the whole tournament so
it's a massive game this one a massive
moment actually there simon because the
king chased away the rook and now we
have two versus three
and to my eyes this looks like it should
be just a draw but it's maybe not an
easy draw because of white's weak pawns
yeah and magnus wants to actually make
it a race uh if white gets time to just
kind of move the king closer to
its pawns and if the white rook gets
chance to defend things
it should just be a draw uh it's just
black doesn't have a passport so magnus
is going to try and create one
i mean that transition where i mean
prague managed to get rid of that black
runner that black past pawn uh okay in
return for one of his own pawns on the
other flank i think that's just maybe
the way he saved the gate he will save
the game
i think it's just
that's why magnus was kind of shaking
his head just really clever from prague
fantastic save if he's if he's able to
still hold this one and that's massive
for the match as well if prague would
have lost
this game
he would have been in a must-win
situation in the two last games because
remember if he's going to win the
tournament he has to win in the rapid
portion prague he needs to take all
three points a draw here and it is very
much still alive for him and this one
should be a draw it's what you guys
mentioned earlier um in terms of when
you're attacking when you have the extra
pawns you want your rook behind to
support the pawns you want your rook
maybe from the side but white's rook is
the one that's going behind black's h
pawn is the only potential winner now so
go behind that pawn stop it from
advancing and
not that much can really go wrong
you can give a few checks to the
blacking if you really want but at some
point you bring your yeah there we go
prague keeps checking at some point you
will bring that white rook to the h file
and
i don't see any way magnus is really
going to make progress
there we go it goes behind the rook yeah
really annoying checks incoming
still some work to be done yeah it's
very instructive how prag just uh knows
these endings he's not even pausing for
thought
he's just
in the memory bank
and giving a check and i'm just checking
the table bases and yeah prague has got
the technique
yeah it doesn't look too difficult now
to be honest
i mean
you can just continue giving another
check with the white rook
you could possibly consider pushing
white's pawn i was wondering it's always
nice in these situations to force the
draw and what that means is if you can
swap off with this move
one more pair of pawns
it is even easier to draw and um there's
a little trick there got to be a bit
careful
this is the right point and he's done it
i mean really brilliant play by prague i
mean i think he's now got the draw in
the bag and what a save what a save from
such a tough position magnus shaking his
head amazing save like how many players
save positions like that against the
world champion
it is a draw game two prague with
phenomenal endgame play he saves the jaw
look at that he has the world number one
sitting by the computer just
looking at the position he was supposed
to win this game magnus carlsen it was
an end game